bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
entretien de France 24 avec nous
aujourd'hui Thierry Vimal vous êtes
écrivain bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de France 24 le 14
juillet 2016 votre fille a mis est
emporté à l'âge de 12 ans à Nice le soir
de la fête nationale française après une
attaque terroriste qui a causé la mort
de 86 personnes et fait plus de 400
blessés trois ans plus tard vous publiez
aux éditions du Cherche-Midi 19 tonnes
au référence au poids lourds qui a
endeuillé la ville de Nice en 2000 22
vous publiez au titre des souffrances
endurées aux charges midi également une
fiction où vous interrogez la société et
les parents et les familles à des
victimes du terrorisme
Thierry Vimal ces deux livres résonne
comme un cri de colère
êtes-vous un père en colère aujourd'hui
je dirais que seul le deuxième livre le
second qui s'appelle au titre des
souffrances endurées est un livre 2 de
colère le premier c'est un le premier
c'est un Christ c'est un hurlement de
douleur qui décide de qui explique
comment trouver un chemin de de survie
dans une horreur pareille qui est
presque un petit peu un petit peu
spirituel qui qui est aussi un tombeau
pour ma fille j'ai voulu quelque chose
de de très beau et de très voilà un peu
spirituel avec qualifié de tombeau
littéraire justement ouais tout à fait
voilà voilà voilà dans ma tête je
voulais vraiment quelque chose de de
très littéraire bon ça a été qualifié de
témoignages forcément mais
[Musique]
voilà et le second livre que j'avais pas
pris j'avais pas prévu de l'écrire ainsi
il est extrêmement différent c'est à
dire qu'après je me suis heurté une
réalité qui est celle de
du parcours de victime victime de
terrorisme mais aussi certainement de
toutes les autres victimes de d'abus
sexuels de violence
le parcours du combattant qu'il faut
faire par rapport aux institutions que
ce soit la je sais pas la justice les
pouvoirs publics les organismes
d'indemnisation
et là là en fait la colère m'est venue à
ce moment-là en fait la colère je l'ai
jamais éprouvé j'ai jamais éprouvé
vis-à-vis du tueur qui quelque part
était un fou comme je dis dans la
chronique dont vous parlerez peut-être
tout à l'heure en fait l'ennemi la jouer
son rôle l'ennemi c'est l'ennemi il
vient il tue c'est c'est terrible on a
envie de riposter on le met parce que
c'est l'ennemi mais c'est quand votre
propre camp n'est pas là quand votre
propre est en faillite et qui est qui
manque à son aide alors là la colère
monte très très fort en réalité vous
décrivez ce que si vivent souvent les
personnes qui sont confrontées à la
justice de manière générale mais la
particulièrement pour cette attaque
terroriste quand vous dites que vous
famille de victimes partie civiles vous
êtes broyé par les institutions c'est
quand même grave c'est la double peine
pour vous d'abord le deuil de vos
proches et ensuite ces institutions qui
vous broie vous voulez dire quoi vous
n'êtes pas pris en charge il y a pas de
psychologue on ne vous explique pas vous
n'êtes pas associé à l'enquête
[Musique]
en gros c'est fait pour
économiser pour
donc voilà le suivi vous me parlez du
suivi suivi médical moi celui que celui
que j'ai eu est satisfaisant celui que
que ma fille a eu satisfaisant après un
niveau institutionnel je sais pas ce
qu'ils ont fait à l'envol il y a des
gens qui disent que c'est très bien
d'autres gens qui disent que c'est que
c'est plus de justement Thierry Limal ce
lundi 5 septembre s'ouvre le procès
justement à Paris de cette attaque
terroriste devant la Cour d'Assise
spécialement constituée je sais que vous
serez présent à ce procès là qu'est-ce
que vous en attendez
ça c'est une question qui revient c'est
la question du moment c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on attend de ce procès et à force de
à force de donc de chercher la réponse
je me suis retiré dans une réponse très
très spirituelle
ou très coaching bien-être
qui dit si vous voulez être heureux
n'attendez pas après les gens si vous
voulez vous réparer n'attendez pas après
les gens donc nous spécialement victime
on a appris on a appris ça on a appris
que si on veut aller mieux il faut pas
attendre après les institutions après le
fond de garantie après les après les
pouvoirs publics et après la justice
donc ce procès si on veut être dans la
sagesse et tout il faut il faut ne rien
en attendre après malgré tout qu'est-ce
que pendant l'attendre et bien que que
il fasse du bien un maximum de gens qui
qui des soif pas les gens qui qu'il aide
les gens à résilier à se réparer mais
j'ai de gros doute j'ai de gros doute
parce que parce qu'il est assez vite ce
procès mais je peux me tromper j'espère
qu'il y aura j'espère qu'il y aura des
temps forts qui se passera des choses
quand même c'est possible vous avez
décidé justement pour ce procès
peut-être une manière aussi de d'avancer
de faire des chroniques judiciaires et
de suivre ce procès de chroniquer mais
des chroniques judiciaires en vert et
non pas en prose c'est une démarche
active pour vous de ces chroniques
judiciaires un peu j'allais littéraire
et puis une manière aussi pour vous de
prendre de la distance par rapport au
procès
ce procès je voulais pas y assister et
je voulais pas non plus en être absent
ça me paraissait donc je trouvais pas ma
place et puis d'un seul coup je me suis
dit mais en fait en fait je vais je vais
le chroniquer mais de
si je le chronique alors chronique
judiciaire si je dirais pas ça je suis
pas assez spécialiste mais enfin une
chronique globale mais je me suis dit si
si je fais ma petite chronique on va
encore parce que j'en ai marre c'est
d'être le le gars qui a écrit des livres
pour se réparer suite à lament de sa
fille alors que j'ai fait toute ma vie
j'ai écrit des phrases dans la com dans
la pige j'avais déjà publié plusieurs
livres bien avant ça donc j'ai pas eu
j'en ai marre d'être rangé dans dans ce
truc là et je voulais pas non plus que
ce soit un travail journalistique et je
me suis dit je vais le faire en vert je
vais faire un verre libre et comme ça ça
sera ça sera inclassable et ça va
attirer l'oeil à tirer l'oreille et
peut-être qu'il y aura un électorat qui
va qui va aimer cette forme là en tout
cas dans votre prologue c'est à la fois
dur direct trash même parfois et puis
humoristique également euh c'est un
espace où de liberté où vous exprimez
mais vous vous donnez quand même souvent
votre avis sur la justice sur le système
judiciaire ce que vous vivez et sur
cette place particulière qu'auront les
parties civils pendant le procès est-ce
que vous sentez ça vous gêne ou alors
vous avez trouvé votre place vous allez
trouver votre place dans ce procès au
sein des participes parce que vous serez
pas le seul évidemment
je lisais non non moi c'est celle de
c'est celle de l'écrivain je l'ai trouvé
sinon autrement avant je la trouvais pas
maintenant je lisais donc hier un avocat
qui expliquait qu'il expliquait assez
client parti civils que s'ils
attendaient des des des des peines pour
les accuser ils allaient être déçus que
ce processus fallait pas le voir comme
ça fallait voir comme un procès pour
pour l'histoire et pour les archives où
donc
oui certainement c'est très bien mais je
pense que du coup du coup je pense que
la justice n'a pas non plus envie
d'entendre d'entendre d'entendre et
d'entendre tellement de participer il
est tellement il y a une amie avocate
qui me disait ils en ont marre parce que
la justice c'est pas c'est pas il y a
cinq semaines qui seront prévues pour
les parties civils pour les témoignages
vous ne voulez pas vous ne souhaitez pas
témoigner à la barre vous
[Musique]
moi tant que les 13 organes de ma fille
dont son cerveau son cœur et ses cordes
vocales sont au frigo à quelques
kilomètres de chez moi et ne sont pas
mis dans non pas rejoint le reste dans
la tombe il est pas il est pas
impensable de commencer à imaginer que
je me reconstruis je tente faire quelque
chose je suis dans la dans la dans la
survie jusqu'à ce que ça ça soit fait ça
ça doit être fait c'est une mission il y
a ça ça se discute pas je suis un père
qui a perdu sa fille je dois lui donner
une sépulture digne donc il y aura rien
rien d'autre qui compte avant
sauf de le faire savoir et faire
connaître ses pratiques là par avec ma
plume
j'ai un parcours indemnitaire aussi qui
est pas fini qui est long et puis il y a
ce procès il y aura-t-il une instruction
à Nice via une instruction
administrative un procès ou non sur
dispositif de sécurité on verra enfin
vous voyez qu'il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui sont pas qui sont
pas bouclés avant de avant d'imaginer de
me retrouver plus que tout seul face à
mon chagrin en me disant qu'est-ce que
je fais très bien merci Thierry avis mal
d'avoir été mon invité pour l'entretien
je renvoie à vos deux ouvrages 19 tonnes
et au titre des souffrances enduré
publiées aux éditions du Cherche Midi et
pour ceux qui souhaitent justement
suivre vos chroniques judiciaires c'est
sur internet le site s'appelle ça passe
crème et ça sera ça sera un compte rendu
du procès jour après jour le procès je
vous rappelle qu'il dure trois mois
jusqu'au mois de décembre merci
anne-mariemen Laouadi à Didier messguard
avoir préparé cet entretien merci à vous
d'avoir suivi à l'entretien de France 24
restez justement sur pour d'autres infos
[Musique]